So stepping up the complexity a tiny bit here, we'll talk about creating masked materials
with some nodes.
So we want to cover the process of how you might create a masked material, we'll talk
about using minus nodes and clamps, and we'll also use the Lerp node to linear
interpolate between two different channels of the material that we want.
We can talk about masking textures for materials using one texture, and we'll also
talk about using the RBG RGB channels to almost get a more performant texture based
on a specific channel rather than the overall texture.
So let's jump into this.
So we've got the process, there are two ways that can be achieved when we're talking
about masked materials.
So with an outside alpha embedded in a texture, or you can do it in a standalone texture
that has an alpha data plugged into opacity.
You can also do this through the color channels, which we were talking about with the RGB
material setup.
When you create a texture sample, you'll have an alpha pin on the texture sample,
which is the main output, and then it's the RGB, and then you've got an A.
So anything imported with some kind of opacity, a 32-bit alpha channel, you can use that
alpha to plug into an opacity of the material.
You can even just pull in a specific channel, whether it's the green channel, the red
channel, the blue channel, to have an alphered material as well, depends on what you
packed into that texture sheet to begin with, but suffice to say there's a number of ways
that we can achieve creating a masked material.
And it's up to your kind of preference and also just workflow of how you're trying
to pack textures together on the approach that you want.
When we're looking at a material setup that we want for thinking about masked materials,
we'll use the minus nodes and some clamps here as well.
So we'll create or use the black and white texture, which we provided in the project,
and you can create a texture sample.
So a nice little shortcut here is if you do use the texture that was given in the
project or anything that's already in your content browser, you can have that selected
in your content browser.
Don't double click it, you can just select it.
You can come into the material and if you press T on your keyboard and left click,
it will first of all create a texture sample, but it'll also automatically apply the texture
that you had selected in your content browser.
So it's just a nice quicker way of working.
Again, you could always just press T or just right click, add a texture sample and
then select the texture after the effect.
It doesn't matter either way, but it's just a little bit more streamlined way of working.
Next we want to create a one minus if we need to flip the masking effect.
So this is our one minus and it'll essentially just flip to the opposite.
So if you've got Alfred on the outside and the solid colors on the inside, the one minus
will then flip it to translucent outside and opaque on the inside.
So it'll just basically flip the effect that you're going for, which you can see
this one minus doing there.
So instead of importing a brand new texture that does the same thing, but in the opposite
way, we can actually just dial that in based on the material, which reduces the amount
of texture samples you might need in your project, which is really useful for having that flexibility.
So we've done this to make some kind of gold trim on the material.
Next we'll create a clamp to keep things in range if parameters are introduced for control.
So if someone programs into your shader, they will see that they have a clamp to keep things
in a nice certain range.
So that's just more of a quality control type of clamp that we've put in there to make
sure we're getting the desired effect.
We can also use lerp nodes, which is a linear interpolate.
So you can just right click, add lerp.
You'll likely see that it's called linear interpolate as well.
And so we'll create a lerp node and run the one minus into the alpha input of the lerp.
And then we want to duplicate that process for the material texture.
So when we talk about duplicating the process, you can actually select these nodes, control
C to copy, control V to paste and just work a little bit more efficiently there.
So you just want to notice that there's not a metal texture for the wood, so we can plug
in a constant into the lerp.
So this is the setup that we're going for here.
You can see that we've got that constant going into the A, we've got the texture
sample going into the B and the alpha is actually based on this texture sample here.
And then when we talk about masking textures for materials using one texture, you can
actually see that we've got, if you go into your texture and you click through the
RGB channels, you'll see there's different information packed into the various channels.
And we can actually just pull off, say the green pin or the red pin in this instance
to get specific information from that channel.
So if in your external app, you've either painted or included some information onto
a specific channel instead of just using the main RGB channel, if you're layering stuff,
for example, in Photoshop, you can just pull off that information in the RGB channel or
even the alpha channel and use that.
And so we call that texture packing.
You can pack multiple textures into one texture when importing it into Unreal.
And it's just a slightly more efficient way to work, especially if you're trying to keep
the texture sample instructions down to a minimum.
So go ahead and follow through those steps.
You can create a mask material, play around with the type of masking approach that you'd like.
Again, we kind of noted two or three different ways that you could create a mask material
based on the texture samples.
And again, it's going to be project specific, depending on what you're trying to achieve.
But hopefully that gives a good overview to the mask materials.
And also just to add at the end of this that we want to credit to Frick for the
scene shown in the RGB channel.
And then we've also got a documentation on how to mask materials, if you'd like to dig
into that topic further.